or smooth agreement reached today to  burn unjustified geo-blocking is without  and adapt the main headline for  competitiveness Council with the general  approach today we gave a clear signal  that consumers should not be refused  based on the ground growth of their  place of residence second item of  today's agenda was single market overall  there was a sense of urgency around the  table due to the deadline imposed by the  European Council to implement the  strategy by 2018 with tangible results I  think the most important from my  perspective of the first one of course  the unitary patent we heard the  announcement of the British Minister  that UK is ready to ratify the package I  think it's a very good news for the  European industry for Europe